welcome everybody uh to this session uh
on industrial strength daily scaling
complex large text and image models
so we have a lot of really interesting
uh content to go through and uh as a
reminder the slides will be found in
this link in the corner you will be able
to also find all of the resources of
this talk
now one of the interesting things is
that uh this topic is advancing
extremely fast
so
um as you may all know uh particularly
people that have been uh keeping an eye
on uh the text to image models now you
would know that uh you know there are
kind of like things coming up pretty
much every day right so whether it is
study or stable diffusion or the latest
uh you know generative large language
models they're a large model or any
large model as we're going to cover in
this session
um you know we want to make sure that
the con Concepts that we're going to be
delving into
um apply Beyond just these examples
so to give you a little bit more of an
overview
today what we want to talk about is a
large x models right so it's not just
language or or text to image but just
basically models that perhaps require
um complex considerations in order to
deploy them
um we will delve into some of the
challenges that often have to be faced
when moving into productionizing these
models we're going to dive into some of
the solutions that can be used for this
and then we're going to be delving into
a very interesting example actually
leveraging two large models in this case
both gpt2 and Dali following by some
closing thoughts
um the resources for today uh you will
be able to find them in this repository
um so this is basically uh on the GitHub
uh you know slash uh Dali runtime uh
which will be played able to play around
um and uh you know just as a brief about
myself uh so um you know as per the
introduction my name is Alejandro I am
engineering director at seldom
Technologies Chief scientist at The
Institute for ethical Ai and governing
member council at large at the ACM
um so ultimately a lot of the tools that
you're going to be seeing today will
leverage uh we'll leverage some of the
open source stack uh from our different
organizations
so first let's dive into the why
right so why are we talking about large
x models and uh the reason is because
we're currently uh finding that even
though there are some query and uh
mind-blowing examples that we're seeing
in the uh you know coming up in in the
internet
um there has been also really
interesting
um applications that have become
practical uh from these large models uh
so developing immersive AI based
application is now becoming a reality uh
you know tools that can allow for
interactive
um you know consumption of these models
are now possible so as practitioners we
now want to ask the question of how do
we uh get value from this uh large
models how can we start actually
productionizing them and using them in
our day-to-day applications now before
diving into into that we need to
understand well what are these large x
models so this uh type of models are
starting to be uh referred to as
Foundation models so tend to be you know
models that are really trained with a
very vast Broad and large uh data set
with also large compute resulting in
models that would as the name imply be a
foundation that are people organizations
can use to build upon right so this
could be building upon for
um you know transfer learning or
actually using uh you know zero shot
learning or n-shot learning for
particular use cases now these models
can have either vertical or horizontal
capabilities and they can be trained
with like very large data sets so this
is actually a really interesting
visualization uh of the data data sets
that have been used for large x models
in this case text-based model and the
size relative size between so the GitHub
model etc etc
so the large uh you know xmos the lxms
have different use cases so this could
be for generating images image
captioning parsing data q a etc etc and
there's a broad range of fast-growing
use cases for which they're using and
another interesting thing before kind of
like delving into the use case is how
there has been a shift uh into how
Academia and Industry uh interplay with
the creation of large of this lxms so
currently we have seen that uh industry
has been growing significantly in in
producing some of these models
particularly because large tech
companies are funding uh those the
creation of these models internally now
it is important uh to mention that there
is a large uh set of organizations that
are producing these models but it is not
just a consideration of producing the
models but the creation of these models
have also
um created a large number of uh you know
uh questions that arise in the context
of responsible AI uh AI ethics and
basically best practices to ensure that
whenever not only these models are being
trained but also they are more
importantly being used
um at scale the considerations are taken
into account proportionate to the risk
that is involved right so if you're
actually taking a large language model
or a large image model or text to image
model and you're actually building an
application for users to consume
um there has to be
um uh best practices that not only have
to be used that have to be applied at
the system level at the practitioner
level but also at the use case level
right and that is of course out of scope
of this talk but if you're interested
there is a recent uh talk that I gave at
last year's Pi data Global uh on uh
practical responsible AI which you can
actually check out on the channel
uh today what we're going to be delving
into is on the productionization
challenges and if we take a step back
and ask the question of well why would
we have to consider some of the
challenges when dealing with lxms or
Foundation models the reason why is
because this type of machine learning
models open different challenges they
actually deal with specialized Hardware
whether it is gpus gpus but also large
number of CPUs or large amount of memory
there are considerations when you're
productionizing this right because if
you have perhaps multiple models you may
want to ensure that you can abstract the
hardware where it runs and if you have
perhaps multiple use cases you may not
want to have a single uh repeated
version of a particular model for every
single use case right because it's
expensive to actually have a running
model you may want to actually have the
multiple use cases leveraging the same
uh resource there are as we will see in
this example potentially complex
dependency graphs right a model may not
be just independent you may not just be
productionizing machine learning model
you may be productionizing a machine
Learning System right and when you have
that consideration you have dependencies
that have to be taken into consideration
given how potential errors may affect
things Downstream and upstream and
Upstream there is a rep a challenge on
reproducibility of environment of code
of data of models that also have to be
taken into consideration and there are
of course the use case-specific
compliance requirements risk
requirements that have to be taken into
account now of course you know this this
challenges themselves make it uh quite
hard if we take every single specific
use case uh you know one by one and we
have kind of the machine learning
engineering teams building custom code
for every single one of them but that's
why we can leverage some of the tooling
existing out there that will help us
actually navigate through this uh
process of productionization uh
personalization of ml and we're going to
be trying to get some sort of ideas
about this with a practical example
today so we're going to be using uh the
Dali Mini model uh so that we can run it
in our computers and I think now it's
called cryon Uh crayon
um and we're not only going to be
deploying a Dali model we're going to
also be deploying a gpt2 model and uh to
make things interesting we're going to
be sending an input to the gpt2 model to
the gpt2 model which is then going to
actually uh go into the Dali model so as
you can imagine the input will then
generate some random text or not random
but some output from gpt2 which
basically generates human-like language
and whatever gpt2 generates we're going
to send it to Dali so we probably are
going to get some weird surprises as we
do this
so the first step of the
productionization challenges we're going
to look at the at these two
reproducibility of components and
compliance requirements making sure that
you can version all of the different
areas of your models as you're
productionizing them so we're going to
be using an open source project called
ml server so ml server is a fast API
based uh
runtime for machine learning models and
these machine learning models can
leverage existing or custom runtimes
right now there are existing runtimes
for ML flow hugging phase scikit-learn
xgboost etc etc and the reason why we're
using this existing server as opposed to
just building something ourselves with
uh flask or fast API
is because this is using several best
practices that have been already battle
tested in production so it comes out of
the box with things like multi-model
serving with a standardized endpoint uh
with a standardized schema uh metadata
discoverability as well as endpoints for
rest grpc and Kafka out of the box as
well as security by Design and of course
you know we're not going to be able to
dive into all of these different things
but if you're interested there are
references at the end of this talk to
dive into each of the different areas in
more detail now how do we interact with
ML server right how do we actually
deploy a model with ML server well so
it's actually pretty simple if we're
leveraging some of the existing runtimes
in this case the hugging phase runtimes
we can actually Leverage The out of the
box uh parameters for the runtime itself
because hogging face itself has access
to the Hawking face Hub we are able to
just provide a reference to the
particular model we are interested on
running right so we basically don't have
to do anything other than provide the
configuration of the plugin face Hub and
in this case we're basically just have
to provide the mod the the name of the
ml server model that we want to load the
actual runtime so in this case we're
using the hugging phase runtime which is
part of the of the ml server server the
number of workers if we are using a GPU
we can use adaptive batching or micro
batching but in this case we're not
going to be using any of those extra
configurations and we can just pass now
the hugging phase specific parameters so
in the hugging phase Hub we can
basically say I want this to be a text
generation model
I want to use the pre-trained model uh
in the hub called digital gpt2 and
whether we want to optimize it or not so
this is basically a hugging phase
specific component to use optimizations
this is all we need because we can
leverage all of the underlying
components if you want to specify a
particular hugging phase model you
actually can and that would just be
custom parameters so once we actually
have this config file the only thing
that we have to do is we just have to
run ml server start that will basically
read that config file and run the
configuration so that we will have an
endpoint that will be available and we
can actually send in this case that
parameter so in this case because it's
the gpt2 model we can send an input
being something like Selden is very
curious about the matter
and when we actually send the request we
will be able to get the response of the
model right so basically what is the
generated mob now let's go to the second
part instead of actually using a
pre-packaged runtime an existing runtime
for the dally model we're going to
create our own python class and this is
how you create your custom runtime and
in this case the only thing that you
have to do for a custom runtime is a
python class with a predict function
right this predict function has all of
the logic that you want to to run as
well as the logic to run any particular
artifacts right so our custom runtime
will first when it initializes we will
load the particular model and whenever
it sends a request it will run this
predict function the thing that it will
do is it will actually first parse
whatever input text it is into the model
and then receive the outputs which is
the image and then return that image
right so is is of course Very simplified
here but it really is as simple as it
looks you're only needing to provide a
custom uh python class with any
initialization logic and you're in it
and any logic in your predict function
we will dive a little bit into that for
this we actually are able to just run ml
server start with our python file the
input can be that you know something
like a rainy day in London and when we
send a request to a model we actually
get the output which is basically here
in you know the actual values of the
pixels the input being a rainy day not
London this is what it generates
so being quite interesting quite simple
now that we actually have the the first
part
um you know we have a fully reproducible
you know Model A an ability to serve it
an ability to version it and we can
actually load both models in the same
server now we actually want to
productionize it how do we deal with the
orchestration the complex graphs
dependencies for this we're going to be
using a framework called seldom core so
this actually uses uh ml server
internally but it orchestrates all of
the configuration for you know the
large-scale deployment in kubernetes
clusters right so we're not going to be
able to delve into a lot of detail a lot
of this is just going to be very high
level but the thing to remember is that
whatever we did with ML server whatever
we run locally
now Southern core is going to allow us
to run it in kubernetes production and
handle basically that inference graph
where we would be able to actually run
the input
um into our gpt2 model uh which then
would go into the actual Dali model and
then uh provide us with a response right
the simple way to do that is the same
way that you would deal with kubernetes
which is just with a configuration file
or a configuration manifest the
parameters here are very similar so we
would provide a graph where the first
step is that Transformer you would use
the hugging phase server the one that we
used in ml server it would then provide
those parameters that we gave initially
so the text generation with digital gpt2
and then the next step of the inference
pipeline would be our daily model which
is using that container that we created
with our you know python class
so this will actually create a endpoint
that will be able to actually uh send a
request and then receive the response of
course again you know this is probably
out of the scope of this talk but you
will be able to actually check some of
these things in the repo and we have you
know I have other talks in the slides
where you will be able to actually see
all of this in practice uh in more
detail with basically you know overviews
how to perform optimization or if you're
more kind of like interested in the
devops how to actually delve into the
kubernetes side but you know given that
this is a data science talk we're going
to be delving more into the python side
now as a data scientist what this will
allow you to do is to perform basically
what we can refer to as segregation of
roles a data scientist can be focused on
training models something like Dali and
basically the machine learning engineer
can be focusing on productionizing those
models into the production environments
like kubernetes so this is just about
segregation of responsibilities making
sure that data scientists can actually
focus on the data science side test in
the local machines make sure that
everything works so that when it's in
the production environment it all just
works out exactly the same but with uh
production grade architecture
now with that we can actually delve into
a demo
so let's have a look we're going to be
using the repo that we showed so this is
basically where you can find all of the
daily runtime components and basically I
have the repo over here so it's
basically cloned
um what we're going to be able to do is
we're going to just follow uh the
instructions that are provided right so
it basically says that in order for us
to run the example uh we have to follow
the instructions in the
um docs slash examples readme file so
this is basically a Jupiter notebook
which we will be able to use and for us
to use the jupyter notebook we have to
just set up our environment so this
runtime provides you with everything to
actually get set up for ML server this
is actually created with one of the ml
server cookie cutters so ml server
itself when it's installed it comes with
a ml server you know project in it
command that basically allows you to to
create like a baseline template this was
then expanded to be able to leverage
that sort of daily runtime it comes with
all of the steps to create the
environment so we would basically first
create our common environment we would
then use uh the install for poetry and
then we would be able to download the
Dali mini models and then basically run
the start so if we actually look at the
commands themselves they're actually
quite simple so you know the conda
create basically just creates it with
the existing environment this basically
installs all of the you know GPU related
stuff in this case they Coulda toolkits
they could DNN
then when we actually install we would
use poetry so poetry ensures that our
environment is fully reproducible
um and you know whatever I'm running you
will have the exact same in your
environment and then we will be able to
actually run the local start
um command which basically just runs ml
server start
um with that example so let's actually
now have a look at the example itself
there's also you know some security
components for being you know production
ready but again this is out of the scope
of this stock for now let's actually
look at that example that is in the docs
folder
so if we look at the example It also
says that the First Command that we want
to run is the ml server start so if we
run ml server start docs example slash
multi-model uh if we have a look before
at what what is in there so if we look
at the multi-model folder we can see
that there is a daily model folder and a
gpt2 folder inside there are those
settings that we talked about so the one
for tpd2 is basically just saying hey
use the hugging face one time and use
basically the parameters to load that is
still gpt2 and then the valley model it
basically just says Hey I want you to
just run this runtime the daily runtime
class so you may ask yourself like well
where does this come from so this is
basically what we are actually creating
as our custom runtime uh whilst we're
using an existing one here this is one
that we created as part of our project
and if you actually have a look this is
basically the python class that we are
referencing here right so this is our
class daily runtime
um so this is the one that actually has
the init uh it loads basically the the
model and then in the predict function
that's when it actually calls that dally
function and you can have a look at that
in more detail
so let's actually first run that command
so ml server start that will actually
basically uh you know run uh ml server
to be uh loading basically uh all of
those models we can now see uh that uh
it's now sort of running on that uh Port
um it now is starting to load those
models first it loads the daily model
successfully uh as we were discussing
um the interesting thing about this is
that we can Leverage The multi-model
serving capabilities so this same server
has also loaded the gpt2 model
successfully right so within the same
endpoint locally now I have loaded both
models what this allows us to do is we
can now actually interact with the
server right so it basically says that
it loaded gpt2 and Valley that means
that if we actually send a request to
the slash models slash gpt2 we can
actually consume whatever is at that
gpt2 endpoint and in this case if we
actually send the input cookies we can
see that the response is our generated
output so here it basically just says
cookies.com uh we actually want
something else uh right because we don't
want to uh try to run badly with uh
cookies.com so okay so here it says uh
cookies can be purchased in a box at the
local grocery store blah blah blah blah
so I think this looks like a nice
um
um uh input for our Dali model right
so now let's actually send this inputs
right so this this result string into
our daily model so now I can actually
send a request again to the same running
server but now to the dialing model
um endpoint right so if we send that
request because we're running it locally
we can actually see
um what's happening so we can see that
this input is now being sort of
tokenized uh we can see that the tokens
are now available here so basically this
would be you know cookies can be
purchased of course you know in order
for the machine learning model to
perform inference Dali has to first uh
you know convert this text inputs into
machine readable uh tokens we can see
that it's actually now uh performing the
sampling of the image tokens right and
now basically what this is what this
means is that it's actually generating
um our uh basically I don't know output
dally model
now what we're going to be doing is once
this actually finishes which basically
it now has this is the image generated
it's now de tokenizing the image and
then it's going to actually send the
response uh that we're going to be able
to to receive here right so now it's
basically finished uh we have the result
over here right so this is basically uh
this this uh parameter we can now
actually process the response right so
this actually has a bunch of utilities
that allows us to do that uh quite
easily and we can convert the response
into a numpy array this numpy array
allows us to display their inputs and
then we can actually see in the input is
some sort of hand over here with
basically cookies generated from that
text so this is actually something that
we have been able to to test locally uh
we can now actually just test and play
around with the daily endpoint right so
again if we actually run you know rainy
uh day in London uh we can see here
basically our tokens right so we can see
a rainy day in London here we can also
see a rainy day in London with basically
the the initial and ending tokens I
would assume
um and you know this this basically just
allows you to actually play with the
Dali mini uh locally as as as you see as
you see fit
um and uh yeah I think I think for now
uh one of the things that we were able
to do is we can also pass some
parameters in this case the parameter is
the seed uh we're just passing the seed
so that we have a consist extend output
so that the images that we generate are
always consistently and we can see that
this is basically what it generates from
a rainy day in London so if you're
interested you know you can play with
this uh you can play around if if and
have some fun uh with with with the
um yeah I guess uh Dali mini Pipeline
and you can then look to productionize
it and deploy it into your production
cluster as you also have not just the uh
commands to run it locally but also the
docker files uh just as a reminder again
the resources for the talk can be found
in the repo uh daily runtime uh the
slides can be found over here so you can
actually access all of that and we have
a bunch of further resources that you
can check out so
um you know resources for cicd for
production at scale production money
monitoring patterns accelerating ml
inference at scale machine learning
security
etc etc so please do check it out uh so
today we were able to cover an overview
of lxms or Foundation models some
challenges in production as well as
Solutions and then this Hands-On example
with uh Dali and gpt2 which produce some
really interesting examples uh so with
that uh I'll pause there
um and uh if we do still have some time
uh I'll pass it over uh for questions so
thank you very much and I hope you
enjoyed uh this session
foreign
I think we have one quick question which
is just uh could uh you share again the
GitHub link for the talk
yeah absolutely and uh yeah just a
reminder that yeah this this link should
should also give you access to the
um slides so that you'll be able to find
all of the uh links uh uh through that
through that so and in the meantime I
will also share
um the GitHub link as well